so i want to talk about some of the the
aspects of virtue that you're talking
about because
i fully agree with this i think that the
the supposed crisis that we're having in
terms of happiness the rise in
the opioid epidemic although some of
that is due to bad diagnoses and people
being given
medical opioids and all of that the rise
in suicide the rise in single motherhood
that in the end these are mostly
personal problems these are people
making bad decisions
and they're making bad decisions because
they've been taught by society by
the government by the culture that if
you make a bad decision it's not really
your fault and the beginning of wisdom
is recognizing that it's probably
your fault where do you think these kind
of where did things start to fall apart
or do you think things are really not
that falling apart
you know it's strange i i there's
pockets that are falling apart
and there's sometimes a malaise that's
or a fog over some things but then
there's entire segments of the
population that are booming
like never before they're in the best
years of their life right now um
and maybe did even under obama you know
they had the best years of their life
and but i mean we share a book in our
faiths in my christian faith through
jewish faith the
book of proverbs the book of wisdom and
all throughout the book of wisdom the
fool
is juxtaposed with the wise the wise
does this the fool does this
the wisdom is this and wisdom is in the
hebrew
you know this probably is the art of
living
life well is really what it means and
that's what we've lost
is wisdom not knowledge but we've lost
wisdom as juxtaposed with a fool and and
if you read through proverbs you go well
i've done that i'm a fool
i've done that so i'm gonna quit doing
that some will be wise in the house of
the wise
are stores of choice food and oil but a
foolish man devours all he has
if you spend everything you make you're
a fool fool fool i've done that
and then when i quit doing that i
actually saved money i had some money
in the house of the wives i mean it was
just it's remarkable isn't it
and so the art of living life well and
when you start to believe that if i
uh plant corn i'm gonna get corn if i'm
gonna reap what i sow if i'm gonna live
in a cause and effect world where i
actually
can impact my own destiny there's
variables around me there's isms
i mean there's racism and sexism and
baldism
there are people that won't do let me do
stuff because i'm bald i haven't been a
bald president elected since television
go look that one up
it's interesting so i mean but i mean
you know these kinds of things are very
we got one with bat hair but we don't
have any with no hair you know i mean
and so jerry ford is not elected but
there's always you know i've got a
southern drawl
and for years in the radio business now
we've got 600 stations but for years
people in boston thought we broadcast
from a double-wide because we're in
tennessee
you know with no shoes you know i mean
there's all these isms right there's
everybody's got an ism they've got to
bust through
i don't care who you are but if you
truly believe because of your ism
whatever it is that you can't win you're
not going to get corn if you plant corn
then why would you ever plant corn
that's hopelessness
and that's the the path of the fool yeah
the the way that i've put it on my own
show is that
i root for reality because there's
nothing else to root for
there's a lot of folks out there who are
rooting against reality and you see this
not only in politics we see it in
culture just the general thing where
people look at their life and they go
exercise and fair here's a person who's
really rich and i'm not really rich and
that's unfair and you see politicians
say this without any solution they just
sort of put it out there and this is
their actual
talking point you say okay well let's
assume for a second that that is
unfair that if you were god you would
even all that out you're not god you're
not evening all that out
and even if you would even all that out
it wouldn't result exactly in what you
want here so
maybe you should stop fighting reality
and deal with reality instead
you know actually wealth equality is
unfair
because effort is not equal smarts is
not equal
i'm not as smart as bill gates he's
helped more people than i've helped
and as a result he has more money i mean
i haven't changed the world with a
computer he did
i'm not steve jobs i didn't do that now
i've made
a good bit of money i've helped a whole
bunch of people um but you know i was
arguing with this
lady a liberal lady and she was mad at
me because i had made a lot of money
selling books to people helping them
with money and she's like well you're
taking advantage of all these people
that are broken i said
you know when i when i sold five books
for ten dollars nobody was mad
but all you people got pissed off when i
sold 10 million of them
and i helped 10 million people and so
the you know your level of return
is the level of help and so that that
just defeats the wealth equality
argument completely
because we now know that 79
of the millionaires in america today 8
out of 10 inherited zero
zero which means they did something in
the marketplace
so the american dream is alive and well
i mean one of the things that i love
about your show is that you actually do
defend the morality of of
the free market and that's something
that very few people are willing to do
in this day and age
it's all about the shortcomings of the
free market income inequality the idea
that people are being exploited and it
seems like they're coming from this
perspective that
even basic elements of life in
the intelligent gaps that this should be
somehow rectified
and you see this with they'll use bill
gates as an example how is there a bill
gates in this country who's worth this
much money and then you'll see somebody
who's worth no money
and you know you say well he's
contributed more he's he's
and they say well but that wasn't his
choice he was smarter right he was
smarter
he grew up better how do you answer that
well he did
you know he and he is and and you know
george clooney's prettier than me so i
mean so what
deal with it i mean you d this is your
hand play your hand
and um you know i was on a we had a
leadership event we did our entree
leadership event last summer and
got to spend some time with condoleezza
rice and she
grew up in a uh in a segregated
neighborhood outside of birmingham
and uh she's she was talking about
coming out of that segregated
neighborhood to
become secretary of state she's
brilliant and uh brilliant lady
and she said my parents told me my whole
life it doesn't matter where where i'm
coming from it matters where you're
going
and you just decide that's what we're
going to do but that has
all this all the way back to do with
this thing called hope and this belief
that if i plant corn
i shouldn't be shocked if i get corn if
i plant nothing i can't gripe about the
farmer who planted corn and was out
there toiling
to kill the weeds and in the hot sun
meanwhile i'm standing over here
watching the guy and then i go well it's
not fair that he's got some corn
i mean i wonder if some of the
complaints that are cropping up
particularly among young people and i
speak a lot on college campuses where
there are a lot of young people who
make exactly these complaints that this
is coming as the result of a breakdown
in religious community because
i'm a religious person you're a
religious person there are a lot of rich
people
people who have been you know i've been
a lot poorer i've been
i've done well that's changed but i've
watched the same thing happen to people
in my
community who i grew up with and so i
know all of them and so it's hard to be
a lot it's a lot
harder to be jealous of the guy that
you've known and grown up with and he
can go to for help
than some random guy on the street we
have no association with and as we
fragment as a community
there's more of a feeling of well maybe
that guy owes me money as opposed to
well i've known my next door neighbor my
entire life we go to the same church or
the same synagogue
the one area of equality that matters
more than any we are equal which is we
are all equal before god right god sees
us all exactly the same
with that breakdown i'm wondering if
maybe that's what's caused a lot of the
feeling of dispossession
well and it's also you know contributes
to racism
also contributes to um arguments between
religion
i mean if you sit down and spend time
with people and actually develop a
relationship with people that have
different situation than you've got
you're going to learn there's good
people
and there's bad people and almost every
one of those things i know wealthy
people
all over the world that are worth
hundreds of million dollars there's some
of the best people on the planet
and i know some of them that'll cut your
throat just to see just to see if you
bleed
i mean and i know some poor people that
are some of the best people on the
planet and i know some of them will cut
your throat having anything to do with
the money
it's got to do with their character or
their lack of it the money just revealed
it
so where do you think the country is
going are you hopeful or pessimistic for
the country you deal a lot with
individuals but on a broad level
where do you think the country is going
right now i mean
my spoiler is that i'm always
pessimistic which is which is great for
me because it means i'm always right
eventually yeah it's just a question of
where the eventually happens
but are you optimistic or pessimistic
about sort of the direction that the
american people seem to be moving
i'm optimistic overall overall there's
lots of issues
there's lots of problems and the i think
the biggest problems we've got are not
structural
and they're not systemic the biggest
problems are belief breakdowns
where people believe the wrong things
and when you believe the wrong things
then you make bad decisions because your
world view is screwed
and that that's what breaks that's what
that's the most pessimistic piece i've
got about it
and so uh to to the extent that we
can people like you can get out here and
be thought leaders and teach people
that they what happens in their house
at the end of the day is probably a lot
more important for the quality of life
they lead over the next several decades
than what happens in the white house
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show sunday special if you
did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all our future
content